one of the scariest parts that sort of
came out of covid was that if you were
accused of spreading misinformation and
misinformation was narrowly defined as
coveted misinformation but now it's
defined more broadly into any
misinformation and so you know
reproductive health and the in the wake
of Roe versus Wade falling if you're
spreading misinformation about
reproductive Health your license is at
risk and so I wrote a piece for the
spectator about the fall of Roe versus
weight and all these things and no one
would talk to me on the record because
they said I I can lose my license and
who defines misinformation and who makes
these decisions all of it is secret and
so I can just get a letter one day that
says I've had my license revoked and so
all of this is permeating through
licensing for Psychiatry for medical to
get into med school you have to answer
questions that you know it's a litmus
test how will you implement Dei in your
professional life as as a medical
professional of any kind
whatever
you've been enjoying me today are the
authors of the new book stolen youth how
radicals are erasing innocence and
indoctrinating a generation Carol
Markowitz and Bethany Mandel Carol
Bethany welcome to the Reuben report
thank you Carol this must be freaking
you out because we usually do this over
Skype or in person when we're drunk
right but here we are sober in the
middle of the day talking about stuff
hard to like not fix my hair and look at
myself you know and Bethany we've never
met before no but you're in the mix of
these uh mothers who are fighting this
lunacy and I just tag along with Carol
basically how did you guys decide to
write a book together I'll go to the new
person first I'm gonna have to blend
this so I don't want to cause a cat
fight here right now
so Carol and I've been friends for a
really long time it's hard to do but
we're friends
and we have very similar World Views and
she writes The Columns that I always
meant to write but didn't get around to
emailing the editor and then I'd read it
and I'm like dang she did that better
than I would have and so we've been
talking about it for years and we had
another iteration of the book proposal
get your village off my children and
then covet hit and we kind of everything
froze and we sort of said let's let's
see where the dust settles and then the
dust settled and we realized like well
get your village off my children is
legit we really need to get them away
from our children and so we said like
you know there is this woke stuff
happening younger and younger and but do
we have enough for a book like is there
enough material here and so we started
Google doc and we just started dumping
stuff in and we realized after a week we
have too much stuff it's the problem
isn't is there a book is like how can we
only write one book about this and how
do we narrow this down and so we just
started plug-in and um you know we had a
lot of interest I mean I don't know how
much you want to say but do you want to
you want to take over this part of the
story well let me maybe do a little bio
part first before we get fully to that
just so that people have a frame of
reference here why don't you both say
like how many kids you have ages things
like that that kind of frame this in a
yeah in a personal way yeah
so Bethany Mandel I am a columnist for
Deseret News and uh Fox News and I like
I write things places and I'm on Twitter
yeah I do the tweets yeah um and I'm an
editor of a children's book series that
is like super patriotic and wonderful
called Heroes of Liberty and I have six
kids age nine and under
six nine and under I just met the two
months yeah you're really going for it
yeah Carol I'm Carol Markowitz I'm a
columnist at the New York Post and Fox
News and I have only three kids which
seems like a lot until you meet Bethany
uh as someone with two three does yeah
you gotta catch up so you guys okay so
you get this google.go and you're
dumping stuff in there trust me I wish I
could wake up on any given day and have
no woke thing to go crazy over so I can
see how this thing would be expanding
and expanding and then how did you
decide to frame it like sort of purely
around education and was that just from
being moms and you were like this is
literally the thing that matters most so
we have two different paths that we have
taken I have kids in public and private
schools I have two sons in public and a
daughter in private and Bethany Home
schools and so what we were seeing was
during covid
um kids were just the last priority they
just completely weren't considered they
would post reopening plans and not even
put children in them they had to live
under restrictions far longer than
anybody else and we saw that it was
really getting to be a problem where
kids were just not considered in society
at all and so our book focuses on that
but also on how schools are targeting
them and publishing companies and
libraries and
um doctors offices all of it targeting
for woke indoctrination are you shocked
at the amount of parents that just go
along with whatever crazy thing happens
next I mean I can tell you as a father
of a six month old and a four-month-old
the idea that you know is it the CDC or
the NIH now you know they want to put in
the schedule yeah the coveted
vaccination for six month olds like
there's no chance in hell right that I
like literally Over My Dead Body but but
they do things and then people just go
along with it was was that shocking to
see or is that just kind of parent 101
no no it's actually the opposite of
parent one-on-one the the parent 101 was
not what parent 101 should be I mean the
way it functions what they what you're
supposed to do is lay your life on the
line and do anything possible to save
your children to help your children in
any way shape or form and what we saw
over covid I'm sorry but was a lot of
parents saying well I don't want to be
the loud mouth I don't want to be the
troublemaker and so they went along with
it one of the craziest things that
happened over covet and our book isn't
just about covert there's so so much
more to it but this sort of drove it
home for me last summer summer of 22
um right that was 22. yeah it's going
faster it really is I sent my kids to a
violin summer camp and sign them up
first day of of summer camp I dropped
them off and every single kid was
wearing a mask and I thought gosh that's
awfully weird didn't think of any
anything of it I was I got a call from
the camp we're requiring masks and I was
completely shocked there's no Mass
mandate in the county no mask mandate in
the park that they're in we we've been
we're past masks why are you requiring
masks only for the summer camp at this
park and they said well it's to protect
the children as if my my biggest
imperative isn't to protect my children
and I came in guns blazing furious and I
pulled my kids out and they said sorry
no refund and I said oh you do not know
who you're dealing with do you and I
said I want the name of your board of
directors I want all of their contact
information and let's have a
conversation about how this bait and
switch situation happened and about how
you have no concern about the future of
children and the well-being of children
and I mean why was I the only parent
that was horrified every other parent
dropped their kid off dutifully in a
mask for a music camp in the middle of
summer in a literal swamp we call do you
see the swamp for a reason it is a swamp
and every single parent would just say
you know this is and I had a lot of work
to do that week I had piled all the rest
of my work that summer including for
this book into that week and I pulled my
kids out and I said okay looks like I'm
not sleeping this week and I did Mommy
camp with them the whole week and from 7
PM until 2 A.M I worked and I don't
understand why more parents didn't take
that perspective so Carol you were I
know this factually you were dealing
with this nonsense in Brooklyn and the
crazy things they were putting your kids
through what what was the snap point for
you
well the snap point was I saw that
nothing was getting better but just to
for a slight defense of parents I would
say that kovid ran into cancel culture
in such a way that parents were afraid
of having their lives destroyed if they
spoke out and if they spoke up and while
that doesn't excuse anybody they should
still be pulling their kids out of camps
and doing stuff like that it does
explain why parents didn't fight harder
at the time people did get fired for
saying this we all pick our battles like
did I mask my kids at moments that I did
not feel comfortable with right
absolutely I did
um but I that summer of 2022 really
killed me right a little bit past the
point where any of this made sense and I
think many people would argue it never
made sense that's a whole other thing
um so when you would talk to other
parents when you do this at the violin
camp or now you're talking to you know
parents at your kids schools like was it
really just fear or is it just that
people actually had no freaking clue
like they're just in in some ways
they're not adults something like that
like that's what we have a Gen X
generation of people that never fully
became adults it was a combination in
Brooklyn I had people who were just like
well the CDC says and if the CDC says
then I do it and the doctors say and I
would be like no the doctors don't
really say but then there were people
who would tell me like I agree with you
but I can't speak up and that was really
terrifying to me um the we opened with a
chapter on the history of totalitarian
societies and how this has happened
before this you know forced Conformity
has happened before and it's happening
here now and it's really scary to watch
I know you mentioned this in your book
don't burn this country and I which I
read you know yeah really good book
um but you know the Conformity thing and
those people feel like they have to say
exactly the right thing in the exact
Right Way really scared people off from
doing the right thing for their kids
yeah again no excuse but I mean
so I really have nothing
so in May of 2020 I said what's the end
point here what's the end game what are
we doing
um I'm not willing to have every single
aspect of our society sacrificed when
the Pediatric wing of our hospital I
mean this was so representative of
everything the Pediatric wing of our
local hospital was converted into a
coveted Ward and sat empty for a year
and so if you had a kid who needed to go
to the ER you had to go farther away no
and um you know tough luck we we've got
to keep it open just in case there's
enough coveted patients to fill it and I
did that and I trended on Twitter for a
full day and you know there are family
members that still won't see us to this
day and that you know we were talking
before the show about how all of this
stuff impacts our kids like my kids will
never see some family members again yeah
well being on this show is not going to
help that department because now you're
gonna have members of my family that
won't talk to you either so add them to
the list that's okay
um what about the the professional class
related to all of this so talking about
like the teacher class and the
administrators whether it's at a school
or at a hospital like were any of them
trying to fight too so part of the
problem is that the people who give them
their licensing the for doctors for
example or teachers colleges are very
um leftist and they teach them how to be
indoctrinators I think Bethany could
speak more to the licensing she wrote
the chapter on it in our book yeah so
one of the scariest parts that sort of
came out of covid
um was that if you were accused of
spreading misinformation and
misinformation was narrowly defined as
coveted misinformation but now it's
defined more broadly into any
misinformation and so you know
reproductive health and the in the wake
of Roe versus Wade falling if you're
spreading misinformation about
reproductive Health your license is at
risk and so I wrote a piece for the
spectator about the fall of Roe versus
weight and all these things and no one
would talk to me on the record because
they said I I can lose my license and
who defines misinformation and who makes
these decisions all of it is secret and
so I can just get a letter one day that
says I've had my license revoked and so
all of this is permeating through
licensing for Psychiatry for medical to
get into med school you have to answer
questions that you know it's a litmus
test how will you implement Dei in your
professional life as as a medical
professional of any kind
um which basically means kill more white
people right like I'm not someone level
right like if you want equity and health
like yeah I mean when we saw with the
code vaccinations the first priority in
which state was it I think well I think
um I think Oregon did it too or maybe
the city of Portland or something yeah
so you didn't get it first if you were a
white male yeah
tough luck Gotta Wait well in actuality
it was probably pretty good but that
wasn't that wasn't the intention what
about the psychological level for your
kids because I remember at the height of
covid craziness I hadn't seen my family
in like six months I was like forget
this I'm going back to New York just to
see my parents and and see my nieces and
nephew and nephews and I go into my
nephew's room and I think he was in
sixth grade at the time maybe fifth
grade and he's got a computer and he's
uh he's in school but like he was also
like playing on his switch and like
doing his thing and I was like Ian like
what's what's the deal with this and
he's like it's so stupid like everybody
knows it's stupid nobody's paying
attention like in the most pure innocent
possible way right
um but the way they destroyed like kids
absolutely the anxiety rates are off the
charts the suicide rates are higher than
ever
um so many things that they did that we
just will never have any kind of
recourse for but yeah what you described
was a really damaging era in the lives
of children that they'll never get back
that's it that childhood moment is gone
um I think part of it is that and going
back to that forced Conformity it's a
way of dividing us it's like what's a
woman what's you know we don't even know
what this means like these are these are
words that have no meaning
um it's a way of making sure that we
stay divided and don't unite over
anything so that they can keep us in
control and that they can keep the kids
indoctrinated yeah yeah and again like
this goes way past just covid but covet
was was a great accelerator for all of
this stuff and you know you can't
revolutionize an entire society when
everyone is happy and content exactly
and so the misery and the anxiety and
the depression of all these kids is the
goal because that's how you further
change because they see that stuff is
messed up and they they need to fix it
and so you know who care who cares if
they lose a couple in the ends justify
the means yeah well that's why I do
believe it's intentional now I I used to
try my best and I still do to some
degree to not go after everybody's
motives but after I mean you I think
moved here a day before I did to Florida
right or the day after me we're right
there right we like landed like probably
within 24 hours of each other up and our
lives come here now you're here your
kids are going to school there's no
chance they're going to be masked or
forced that changes literally everything
right and again it's not just the
masking right because apparently we're
past covet Joe Biden says
um but for that emergency orders
25 right it's coming um but you know the
the whole Ron DeSantis not allowing woke
nonsense in schools which means that my
kids who are in public school I feel
safer with them at at those schools and
I I'm not I don't worry about them as
much um they don't have like 12 trans
friends each because it just hasn't hit
here in the same way that hit New York
but the thing that we always say is that
you shouldn't feel
safe and confident if you live in a red
area it's coming to you to the teachers
go to the teachers colleges where they
learn Marxism which they pass along to
your children this is happening
everywhere I've heard we heard from
people in small towns and rural areas
and deep red States and they were all
saying my kids are getting it too what
do you say is the ultimate answer to
this at the school level I mean is it
pure school choice and funding students
instead of systems instead of systems
and and doing the homeschooling thing I
mean is it basically obliterating we
have education as we know it we have
different paths but you talk about yours
first yeah so we homeschool and I have
no intention of doing otherwise I mean I
don't live in a red State I live in the
most liberal County in a quite liberal
State I live Montgomery County Maryland
why is Montgomery County gone so bananas
every time uh every time I see something
out of Montgomery it's like it's like
Beyond it seems like it's part of it is
because a lot of us journalist folks
live there and so that's it we I mean
that crazy right so the stories that we
are we are getting published on Fox News
and I like I have a hand in a lot of
them a lot of the stuff that gets
published I'm feeding to people because
it's not my zone but I want it out there
and it's because I have the privilege of
having the email address of a Fox news
reporter
um there's people in Indiana and in
Oklahoma who don't have that privilege
doesn't mean it's not happening there
and so you know for us like we
homeschool and we are very choosy about
the friends that our kids have but I I
mean I my DMs on Twitter are a
repository of all of the crazy mcps
stories but what's really sort of crazy
is that they are so open about it
they're so proud about it and so a lot
of the stuff that I end up passing on to
Fox news reporters is stuff that they've
posted publicly
well it's sort of like Libs of tick tock
right people were like oh she's
attacking these people but literally
she's reposting their own videos so how
do you differ in terms of that I mean my
kids are
we really lay the law
this is what we believe leave and these
are the values that we want you to carry
out into the world and so a lot of it
requires being really honest with our
children about our beliefs because
parents say that oh we don't we don't
really talk about with our kids about
that well we don't talk about
necessarily politics we don't talk to
them about like which political
candidates we like or anything like that
um but we do talk to them about values
and that's important you want to get the
message to your kids and you want to lay
the foundation for them because a lot of
the time you will have to let them go
eventually they will get to college and
they'll be they'll face this wokeness no
matter how much you've protected them
and it's important that they know where
they came from yeah and and I I mean not
just tell them but also live it I mean
they watched me scream at Montgomery
County the County Council on Zoom
meetings and I would sit there for an
hour and 45 minutes and they never tell
you your time slot for speaking for two
minutes so you have to sit there and so
there's one video of me holding one of
my babies and they turn on the camera
and you're I was the first one
testifying for this portion of the
County Council Bill and so I just let
Lou and started screaming at them and my
kids at the end of it were like first of
all you're terrifying I do not want to
go inside school tomorrow
they like sort of avoided me for the
next four hours but they saw that I was
screaming about them I was yelling at
them about how kids were being treated
about how my son was yelled at in a
supermarket because he wasn't wearing a
mask because I wasn't just because I'll
play along to go into the supermarket
doesn't mean I'm gonna beat my kids to
do it and so my kid got yelled at in the
supermarket and I said this is your
fault Montgomery County Public like the
County Council and they saw I was
fighting for them and that is really
powerful and they got it and I mean they
saw that we were you know the the front
lawn sign for the school board candidate
that we were supporting that was not
just for my kids who are public who are
not in the public school but it's for
our literally our neighbors kids right
um because the woke infestation isn't
just impacting sort of all of this idea
logical indoctrination but it's also
impacting the quality of Education
that's happening in these schools at the
elementary school around the corner my
daughter would be in fourth grade in
that school less than five percent of
kids are performing on level in math and
I think seven percent in English I mean
your famous tagline every minute spent
on wokeness is not spent on math or
reading or science it's just it's a Time
suck from those subjects isn't that the
extraordinary part of this yeah one of
the things that I whenever I give a
speech about this stuff I always say to
people it's like picture your third
grade teacher now picture that woman
it's most likely a woman at least if
you're of a certain age picture that
woman talking about sex with you it's so
insane when I picture Mrs cochinella who
I thought was 120. she was maybe 55 but
I just thought she was like the oldest
thing ever and like she read a secret
garden the idea that she would have
secretly like in a small room been like
talking to me maybe your penis is a
vagina like it's so bananas and yet I'm
not that old like that that's you know
you know 30 something years ago yeah
well the secrecy is a big part of it
another thing that I like to say is that
leftism is very unpopular it only seven
percent of the country represents
considers themselves very liberal so
that means that 93 don't and that 93 is
the majority obviously but they also
they don't feel like the majority
because that seven percent is so loud
and they do what they do through force
and they don't like they they kind of uh
push their way into our society and that
93 has to realize that they can stand up
and fight them when you have moments
like that like the Zoom thing or
something goes viral and blah blah blah
I assume all right you're going to get a
ton of hate and I you every now and
again you repost some of the hate and
they say rather unpleasant things about
you
um but I'm sure your inbox also blows up
with a lot of parents that are like
thank you and like how do they do they
want to get involved or they just want
to encourage you to keep fighting for
them because I used to get a lot of that
when I was leaving the left it was like
people didn't want to do it but they
wanted to encourage me to keep taking
the bullets which at some point starts
getting annoying and it's and then you
start resenting those people in a weird
way because it's like you're not
Superman or Superwoman right yeah yeah I
mean people would ask me you know how
can we get the masks off in the schools
how can I how can I switch and my answer
is switch daycares yeah and and they
were just well it's really convenient
it's close to my office okay and that's
your bed and you've decided to lie in it
or fight but you can't email me doesn't
do anything exactly like I actually
don't run your daycare so
um I would take off The Masks if I did
but yeah you know you need you have to
stand up and you have to fight parenting
is not easy as you might know yeah
um and it's it's not sometimes they pee
forget the right thing right like it's
just a lot yeah they do pee a lot
um but you know the thing is that you're
going to have to stand up for your
children and if you don't stand up for
them they're going to be influenced
outside of your sphere and you will lose
them it happens all the time and it's
you know all of this work of getting
peed on for 18 years goes out the window
what's easier right like I'm like listen
if you're gonna pee on me at least
you're gonna take some of my ideas with
me into life I would I would hope that's
the goal
um where are you at now like in terms of
do you think that you know the seven
percent versus the 93 like are things
changing you know I know we have our
very microcosm version of it in Florida
which feels very disconnected as I said
and the thing we did the other day to
the governor it's like my show I do all
of the craziness for a half hour and
then I finish up with 15 minutes of
Florida sanity so I have this huge uh at
odds view of the world at the moment
yeah well Dave and I are obviously in
like Florida la la land where everything
really is so much saner you know we live
in Florida
right now
100 pieces about it
um I but I am so happy about that and I
feel so much more comfortable with the
kids because I don't worry about them as
much I in the book um I write a lot
about the Florida Move obviously and in
the acknowledgments I think the governor
and the first lady for giving us this
place of normalcy and what I'd say in my
chapter about what to do about this
wokeness is you might have to move you
might have to switch States you might
have to switch communities it it maybe
it's as easy as switching schools but
you you have to do this for your kids
the last word in the book is fight and
we really mean it you have to fight for
your children yeah yeah I I mean do I
have hope I I hope for our kids our kids
sure I mean I've never met them all
right so far you know it's starting to
babble a little bit yeah I mean my
nine-year-old is going to marry her 10
year old so we're really in her for the
Long Haul we've got to line them up
but I mean
I am encouraged that a lot of parents
were horrified over coveted not just
over covet obviously but also you know
they got a peek at what their kids were
learning and they were not happy about
it
um and I think that you know test scores
hitting the news is is good and I think
that people are are recoiling more and
more in horror at those things but you
know we cover a lot of things in the
book that people don't really know about
um the medical chapter to me was one of
the most terrifying to write
um there are so many instances in big
ways and small ways that this woke
infestation through I mean we talked
about a little bit with the licensing
with med school applications uh at a
conference for for you know neonatal
doctors they canceled a panel That was
supposed to sort of teach doctors about
the latest technology for uh premature
premature thank you uh premature babies
and they canceled the panel because
there weren't enough women and and
people of color on the panel so given
the choice between educating doctors in
the latest technology or being woke they
decided to be woke yeah and so all of
these things have an impact on medical
Innovation and it's it doesn't end in a
good place and so that's that's the
stuff that scares me
um and also in the children's literature
space it is so crazy now and getting
crazier and crazier and it's because I
mean I talked this was one of the things
I talk about in the book I talked to
Librarians and editors at Big publishing
houses and they said the incentive is to
go woke because the library is buying us
in bulk and individual families only buy
us single books so you know this is this
is the situation that we have and people
assume that you know when they're in a
doctor's office they're safe or if
they're reading they're safe
and you can't assume anymore where do
you think the media plays into this
because even with what's going on now
with DeSantis going after the AP
African-American studies course because
it was teaching gender queer Theory and
did you know that Harriet Tubman was
running an underground lesbian bar I
mean like it's all so stupid but the way
they frame everything is is so
profoundly dishonest that parents
parents watch The View and they hear
them say okay they're not going to teach
slavery in Florida and then they every
it's like this systemic everyone is the
word systemic but it's like this
systemic stupidening stupid inning I
like it of everyone basically yeah
absolutely but DeSantis manages to get
past that he manages to out talk The
View right I think that that's the the
case when given the opportunity but the
problem is so I think DeSantis handles
it very well and one of I think it was
and and MSNBC asked his office for our
comment and they said we will not be
commenting yeah that was after the
Andrea Mitchell absolute lie why does
Rhonda Sanders not want to teach slavery
the reason I'm asking that question
though is because you know there was
this uh the book that was taken out so
far the only book what was it it was the
gender what was it gender Theory I
remember I don't know what it was called
but yeah but they were literally
teaching kids how to give hand jobs yeah
why would you want that in a school I
mean when did you guys ever talk to
these people and were you able to like
Whittle it down to that with any of the
people that you're fighting with like
they have the the grand woke idea but
did you ever like get it to them in that
at that no we have a chapter on
sexuality yeah yeah I mean at the end of
the day all parents are bigots and not
woke enough and it is their job it is
their sacred duty to save our children
from their parents
yeah but the thing is that they're also
not having children yeah they're they
want to indoctrinate our children
they're not having any um they're all
anti-natalies yeah their fertility rates
are really low so it you know it ends up
happening that they don't have kids and
they're they don't want your kids to
have this information and the thing is
the secrecy is such a big part of it
they don't run on you know let's get
porn into schools they run on you know
oh we're gonna have great books in our
library but then they end up having
stuff like that
what is going on with whether these
teachers are actually dealt with or not
so like when Libs of tick tock puts up
these videos of these teachers and they
clearly are they're saying exactly what
you say that they say it themselves
these are our kids they're not and they
they view themselves as the savior of
these children
are you being fired like I know in
Florida a couple of them have like
I'm guessing in Montgomery County it's
probably not happening like they're no
so that in that regard it's still
strengthening in some respects yeah no I
mean it is it is part of the job
description to be woke you I mean the
number of teachers that I've heard from
who say I am not comfortable and I don't
know what to do that's to me some of the
most discouraging stuff because
what can they do I don't want them to
quit I don't want everyone to be insane
in these schools but there's there they
have to sort of abide by the
superintendent the principal the
curriculum developers and so they're
really stuck between a rock and a hard
place and they feel this obligation to
students but they know that they are
it's a David and Goliath fight uh
genderqueer by the way is the name of
the book oh yeah that's the main one
that has been taken out of the Florida
school so while the media is running
around saying 1.5 million books have
been taken out of Florida schools it's
all complete nonsense what about at the
at the race level because we've talked
about it sort of at the covid level and
a bit at the gender and sexuality level
what's going on at the race level your
kids are white supremacists well they're
Jews so that's not good I don't know if
they're white right now or not it's like
you know it just depends on the week
yeah it really does depend on
um the funny thing is that CRT was
somewhat beat back it was uh that really
hit when everybody was paying attention
and when CRT uh the concept of it was
introduced to parents they saw how
noxious it was
um and I think that that that it
provides kind of a road map of what to
do and it and the parents should emulate
that in the gender fight it's it's a
very similar struggle I mean I think a
lot of parents of color also were
horrified by CRTs and that was a really
powerful voice because they said do not
teach my children that they are victims
do not teach my children that we have to
lower standards so that they can succeed
my child can succeed against anyone in
your school and please stop telling them
otherwise because that's what's really
you know we want to talk about racism
the racism and low expectations is
really what's harming those kids and so
those voices of black parents were
really really powerful in the fight
against CRT but I think also with the
gender stuff
it's it's a lot harder to speak up
because it's all sort of lumped together
and you're just a generalized bigot
um which I I mean people that could be
the title of my next book
that's pretty good yeah you got a
particular thing about the way you said
bigot that seemed particularly uh strong
there I mean to some extent okay it's
growing people are fighting back does
this just leave us in what we've come to
the conclusion of that it's just the
state and the local community and lower
and lower lower like is there any hope
at the federal level that any of this
will I don't know I don't know that
there's hope for the government to do
anything but I do think the pendulum is
swinging and that
um parents even in blue areas are kind
of had enough of all this and it's
partly because their test scores are
plummeting and we see that their kids
are not learning anything so I think
that um even the delayed speech thing
which is oh it's huge yeah it seems like
almost every kid now and obviously
that's a bit of an exaggeration but has
some level of speech deficiency that
simply was not the way it was back in
the day no I mean I've spoken to speech
language Pathologists my older two kids
were speech delayed um my nine and my
seven-year-old and so I knew immediately
when we started putting masks both on
kids but also on their on their child
care providers that this was going to
and badly and it's not just that but
it's also the reading I have a
kindergartner who I'm teaching how to
read and I was teaching him something
recently and oh it was the word black
which funny enough since I'm a racist
also and so he could not figure it out
and I said watch my lips
and then he as soon as my lips went
between my teeth he said L how were they
teaching reading for two years and so I
I think that you know being lied to and
told that the sky isn't blue so many
times really sort of woke a lot of
parents up
um but the the level of delays I think
we're only just starting to realize and
and I've seen data from speech language
Pathologists that like we're we're in
for a rough road and if there's any of
your viewers out there who are in
college thinking about their their
future life plans child psychologists
speech language Pathologists
occupational therapist very safe jobs
yeah how worried are you that I don't
know that you covered this in the book
but that like this generation of kids is
going to grow up and really do horrible
things to to their parents in some ways
like I really mean it like like
literally when they're checking them
into the home being like no no you're
going to the cheaper home and like that
at some point they'll realize you know
because they were also drugged probably
prescription drugs and not going to
school and masks on the face and you
even see it now at the airport you'll
see parents without masks and they've
still got the kids in The Mask like I
actually think there is going to be a
real generational thing there I mean
that's if you know if it doesn't take if
it's not like that those kids are doing
the same thing to their kids which would
be right right right which are case
scenarios I think um I'm not that I'm
saying anybody should be throwing
anybody in a home or anything like that
um I have six kids I'm probably safe
probably like you just need one of my
other friends are really in my favor
you're gonna be fine what else are you
guys hitting in here that that you know
beyond Okay so we've got gender we've
got covid we've got race stuff we've
sort of move to where you're supposed to
be kind of thing yeah the medical
chapter
um the history chapter that we open with
I think will be eye opening for people
that I don't think they think about it
as something that has happened in
history before it's it's not new this
indoctrination thing they do this to
kids in totalitarian societies and we
happen to be going through a very
similar period
um I I would say that throughout my life
people have said to me because I was
born in the Soviet Union do you feel
like this is very Soviet and I would
always say no no nothing no the Clinton
years no they don't feel very so weird
to me but this does and the way that
people told on each other during covets
neighbors calling the police on each
other the way that they socially
pressured each other to only have a very
narrow set of opinions you know if you
think schools should open that means you
want teachers to die and that sort of
thing it was very reminiscent of the
stories of my youth like the things that
my grandmother would tell me about like
your friends turning on you because you
weren't politically correct
um and it's scary because this change
how you guys
do family structure things as well
because you know they're obviously
trying to infiltrate the family like did
it did it shift anything in terms of how
you deal with
or just your internal literally your
home so when I was writing the the
chapter on entertainment media I spent a
lot of time on literature because I
think that folks are now pretty
understanding of the fact that you know
when they turn on the TV Disney
everything is woke but the insidiousness
of it in the children's literature space
I think is very shocking and I was
talking to two mothers one week
um and both of them mentioned the same
book a graphic novel for middle grade
kids so like
7 to 12 or so and it's for girls and
it's about girl soccer players and both
of them told me there's a sex scene in
it between two girls at a sleepover and
I was like I don't want my daughter
thinking she can have a sexual encounter
at a sleepover yeah that seems like a
road that I that I don't want to open
and I the second time the mother
described it in more detail I thought
girl soccer player graphic novel what
did we pick up at the library last week
because I feel like that sounds familiar
and I hung up the phone got my iPhone
flashlight out opened my trunk went into
the bag with the library books and there
it was and I said oh well I could quote
this extensively because my daughter
picked it out at the library this week
and I hadn't brought the book in and I
said that's it for us at the library I'm
done and it was ironic because I spent
all of covet fighting with my local
library to reopen I don't remember the
last time I've been there isn't it weird
How It ultimately became a war on
normalcy like remember when Megyn Kelly
finally had her like final straw with
all this after they were doing all of
this stuff at her kid's school on the
upper west side and then she took a
picture I think of a bookstore that I
used to live a block away from on
Amsterdam and 83rd and it was just like
it was literally like woke soup
superheroes or something in the in the
bookstore window and then she was like
okay I gotta leave the city like that
they just everywhere that's really what
it was it was the war on normalcy I
think that that's what drove us out of
New York it was that we didn't see
normalcy returning like for a while and
and childhood very short so we didn't
want our kids to be growing up in that
and I think that's the that's the real
thing parents need to give their kids
that stability and normalcy so that they
grow up and they're resilient and that's
that's the goal raising resilient
children yeah well Bethany you walked in
here with a two-month-old who then you
handed to my assistant we haven't heard
anything in the last 40 minutes so I
feel like it's probably going okay out
there or she's taken him in which case I
have five spares good luck to her any
final thoughts ladies
we will link to the book down below and
we'll do our best to get you on the New
York Times bestseller list but of course
you know that's completely made up
because they're woke and they are not uh
right yeah exactly well that's the thing
that's the thing that you know really
people should understand is that this
has permeated everything you think that
something is is normal or or fair or um
standard and it's not and New York Times
bestseller list is a great example of
that where it doesn't matter how many
books you sell the Greta uh thumbberg
example she was on the bestseller list
last week with 4 000 books I'm sure that
you sold more um way more way more two
possibly number one from my last book
they didn't even put me on it yeah that
was my first book they put me at 11 when
I should have been four that that's
really what I saw ten times more than
number four yeah that's what we're
fighting here it's that this abnormal
behavior and this push of just one
Viewpoint is for meeting everything and
you have to keep your kids from it yeah
yeah I mean the final thought for me is
the resilience chapter that was the last
chapter that I wrote and told a very
personal story of my mom passing away in
the circumstances of that when I was 16
years old I was the one that pulled the
plug spoiler alert
um and I was raised resilient and I went
to a therapist who gave me some tough
love and said do not Define yourself as
a victim this is not who you want to if
it's not who you want to be do not
Define yourself as such what are the
chances of a 16 year old Bethany today
having a therapist who would say that to
her now victimhood is the goal it's not
something that you want to avoid and
it's creating a generation of children
who are not just not resilient but who
are basket cases and that's the goal
all right well to end this why don't we
do what we can reveal our plan now you
guys went through this whole process of
writing this whole book coming here Etc
et cetera but it was really
should we go over there
with my one series of my two-month-old
there is no flight back and your child
has been taken by my assistant it's been
a pleasure ladies it was really nice the
book is stolen youth the link is right
down below
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell